And that sometimes
the experiences we can create
can be detrimental,
if not dangerous to our democracy,
to equity in our society,
to so, so many things.
Noam Segal,
thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you today?
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm good, thanks.
It's a wonderful pleasure.
I'm addicted to thinking about
user behavior and user research.
So, this is like an entertainment
for me right now these next 20 minutes.
As if I'm watching my favorite TV show.
I'm very excited.
Where are you calling from right now?
I am in Mountain View, California,
right by the Google headquarters.
Lovely.
So, I'm not going to do a service to you,
by reading the whole introduction.
I'm going to let you talk a little bit
about your journey.
But, you know, just for the ear.
You were a lead researcher within Airbnb,
previously in the IDC, and the Air Force
and a bunch of other companies
along the way, most recently now
heading the user research
at the Wealthfront,
a company that I deeply admire.
Actually, I believe the founder
of Wealthfront was one of my professors
at Stanford about financials,
Andy Rachleff.
So, Noam, take me back.
Why user research?
Why user experience?
And what is user research in its core?
Well, I kind of I would say
got into the realm of UX by chance.
I was born and raised in Israel,
though I sound suspiciously British
because both of my parents are.
And I served in the military,
in a unit within the Air Force,
which is in charge
of Israel's missile defense system.
And when I left the Army
after five years or so, I joined Elbit.
A company in Israel,
which it builds a lot of things.
It's part of the military industries.
I joined the team building those
same missile defense systems.
I was operating in the military
and my interest and my focus
was on the user experience
of those systems, except,
we didn't call it user experience
at that point.
And I didn't have that much expertise,
if any, really, besides being
an operator of these systems.
And then throughout the rest of my career
since then, I've mainly
just been trying to build my expertise
specifically around research.
And so at some point,
I decided to leave israel,
moved to the US, to central Illinois,
amidst the cotton fields of Illinois
and get my PhD in psychology.
Really? Wow.
Yeah.
And really level up
my research skills that way.
But at some point, I realized throughout
that my passions are tech and research.
And the marriage of tech research
is the field of UX research.
And so I'm really glad that I got to
move to Silicon Valley,
where I know you typically live as well,
and work for these incredible,
incredible companies,
Airbnb, Intercom,
and these days, Wealthfront.
What does it mean, though,
to enter a company as a user researcher?
Because at the end,
the company, you know,
there's a bunch of different functions
that you think of
when you think of a startup
or a big company, right?
All the way from the
research and development,
all the way to the financials
and to the strategics in the marketing.
But the user research,
user experience field,
it sounds to me a little blurry
about where that flies.
Is it in marketing? Is it in R&D?
Where is that?
So, a couple of things.
First of all, the way I think of it is,
and you know this,
there is incredible talent
here in Silicon Valley
and across the US and Israel, of course.
And there are also,
VCs we have access to
every single imaginable resource
we could need to build anything. Right?
Servers are cheap
and graphic cards are cheap
and memories cheap.
And we have tools coming out of our ears.
We have so many tools.
We have everything we need.
But just because we have
all of those resources
and all of that talent, doesn't mean
we should just build anything.
It doesn't mean
every idea has equal value.
And it doesn't mean
that that idea will serve people.
So, we need to understand people,
we need to understand how people think
and how people behave
and what attitude people have.
Because ultimately any
successful startup,
any successful startup
starts with a problem.
A deep, meaningful problem
that possesses people
and founders of those companies.
And ultimately,
when you solve that problem
in a way that makes sense, thanks to,
among other things, research,
it makes all the difference in the world.
And that's what creates
incredible companies.
Now, UX research is typically under one
of two kind of organizational umbrellas
to your question, either the design team
or the product team,
depending on the company.
So, I've reported into both.
These days, my manager
is the VP of design
at Wealthfront, but I've also reported
into products in the past.
It really depends on the organization.
So, what is the job actually, entail?
Because, you know,
a lot of people run by intuition
when they're developing the product
and are thinking of a product,
they're imagining what
the user will want.
They are taking that assumption and
they're just developing based on that.
What is the impact that a research,
a user researcher can have
on an organization?
So, the problem most founders tackle
is that they are not their users.
Sometimes, rarely you may be your user,
but usually you're not.
And so, you need to go to your users.
This is something that Paul Graham
famously told the Airbnb founders
when they waltzed into his office
for their weekly meeting
where they went Y Combinator.
And he asked them,
"Where are your users?"
And they told him,
the 20 or 30 users we have at that point
are all in New York
or they're mostly New York.
So, he said, you know,
"What are you doing here?"
"Go to your users.
Go to New York. Talk to them."
And they realized so many things
from that trip.
One of them famously was that
the places that the hosts were hosting
in their homes, their apartments,
they weren't well photographed.
And people weren't really getting to see
and imagine the awesomeness
of these places they could stay at.
So, Joe Gebbia,
one of the founders of Airbnb,
ended up photographing
the host apartments.
And that was the beginning
of a very important characteristic
of Airbnb, which was
beautifully presenting
hosts homes and apartments.
And ever since then,
ever since then and before then,
whether it's at Airbnb or anywhere else,
user researchers in particular
have been going to users.
And that can be done through
a variety of methods.
It can be done in normal times,
if we don't have a pandemic, in person,
by travelling to users
all over the world.
It can also be done
in much more quantitative ways,
such as setting up to serve survey
or watching users as they use a product.
But whatever method it is,
ultimately we give to our users
because we recognize that
we are usually not them.
And we need to understand
how they see this.
Right.
And I believe that,
from the very small
experience that I have
in user research,
and in my military service,
I was responsible for building products
that hopefully intelligence people
will love using,
and part of the challenge that I faced
was going to these users
and I would know who my users are.
They definitely weren't me,
but I knew who they are.
And I was with them.
And I would ask them a lot.
Hey, what do you need?
Why is this difficult for you?
What would you like to see?
And there is the famous quote, right?
If one hundred years ago,
you would ask people
like what they need to get
from point A to point B,
they would want faster horses.
So, how do you tackle that,
you know, as a researcher
when the people that you're talking to
don't even necessarily know
what they want and you almost have to
read between the lines
and extract that aha moment?
That's exactly the point.
We often talk about in our field
that we are not trying to establish
what people want.
We are trying to establish
what they need.
And again, that all starts with a problem.
We're not looking
to people for solutions.
We're not asking people who
have a carriage with a horse
what they want
because they would say faster horses.
What we're trying to understand is
the fact that you only have
a carriage with a horse,
what problem does
that create in your life.
You know, it's that problem that,
is it that you're not able to get
from point A to B fast enough,
or is it something else, perhaps.
And so, I'm not sure what led Ford
and the original car makers
to make the car.
But I can imagine,
it's some of those problems.
So, the key here is
where you keep your focus.
And most research frameworks
help you focus on the needs
and the problem, not what people want.
Again, we have incredible.
Incredible talent here,
amazing designers, amazing engineers,
we can take care of that stuff.
We just need to understand
what the problem underlying.
So, when you approach a challenge
and I'm assuming that a lot of the times
you're approaching these challenges
and you have to start from scratch.
And you have to get to know
what the product is,
get to know who the potential users are
and get introduced to a whole new domain.
What is your process?
How do you go from A to Z
and understanding to then give
some concrete feedback to whether
it's the VP product or VP design,
or whatever it is
on how this product should be
actually built or thought of?
Yeah.
So, first of all,
it's a very collaborative process.
And that's something that is,
is just growing, I would say,
in the research community.
We work in cross-functional teams.
We work with designers
and engineers and PMs.
And it's important to mention that.
And we start broad, right?
We look at the market,
we look at the competition,
we look at what exists today.
We do a lot of secondary research,
not just primary research.
So primary research is where you actually
go to a user and ask them questions.
But secondary research is just looking
at what we know from academia,
looking at what we know from competition,
looking at what we know
from a bunch of different things.
And then usually start
more on the qualitative side
by simply talking to people.
Because we don't know
what we should even be asking them
in the first place.
We don't know
what they're trying to tackle.
For example,
a few years ago with Wealthfront,
this was about finances.
This was about investing.
You mentioned, Andy,
was your professor at Stanford.
It's one the most popular classes
at Stanford, I think,
the class he teaches.
And he realized that
young people, especially,
you know, the sort of people
that were his students at Stanford,
didn't have access to investing tools,
to the same sophisticated tools
that used to be only, you know,
for the wealthy and the very well-to-do.
Right?
Who would have imagined 10 years later
that you could leverage tools
like tax-loss harvesting,
even if you don't have a million dollars
in your investment accounts, you know.
So, this is a paradigm change
or this was a paradigm
change in investing
and just one of many, many examples.
Is this an industry that's evolving,
the industry of user research
and user experience?
Do you see from when you started
to where it is today,
is it more popular
or have the methods evolved?
It's maturing a lot.
So, first of all,
the experiences we're creating
are so much more complex
than ever before.
We are able to build
incredible software these days.
But those experiences
are very, very complex.
And so, more and more research is needed
in order to craft them.
We're also slowly but surely
transitioning to completely new platforms
that people have never experienced.
You know, my kids,
who are five and one right now,
they're not going to drive cars.
And they're not going to use
huge phones like I do,
because there's a limit to how big
you can make a phone screen.
And they might live
in some mixed reality,
which I'm not sure exactly
what it will look like, but it's coming.
And so, you have
more and more complex experiences.
You have completely new platforms,
up and coming platforms which require
a whole new understanding
of human perception, human abilities
and new problems
at these platforms and so on.
And in addition,
the field is maturing in other ways.
For example,
one of the things we've seen
on the development side
and the design side
and the research side is the rise
of ops, of operations, dev ops,
design ops, research ops.
As researchers these days we have
so many more tools and processes
and things to take care of.
And so, the field
of research ops has been
really burgeoning in the past few years.
And then one more thing
I feel like I have to say is that,
I think, we have also come to realize
in the past few years,
way too late, if you ask me,
that we have great responsibilities
in tech. And that sometimes,
the experiences we can create
can be detrimental,
if not dangerous, to our democracy,
to equity in our society,
just so, so many things.
And so companies are thankfully investing
more than they have before
in doing that research as well.
And making sure
the platforms are accessible,
making sure that things are
more ethical than before,
more equitable than before.
That's another important component
of what we do in research.
Wow. And obviously,
being a user researcher at a wealth
management company, in that space,
it's a lot of responsibility.
It's a lot of responsibility not just
for the company to continue succeeding
in knowing its users,
but it's also a responsibility for knowing
what the users actually need
and how to create, you know,
delight moments that are
actually beneficial to the users
and not detrimental to them.
And I took a lot of inspiration
from one of the classes I had
at Stanford by Floodgate.
It was a venture capital class.
We were talking about these
delight moments
that a lot of companies
are trying to create.
And it seems that not all of these
delight moments are actually beneficial
to the users.
They could be sort of artificial.
They could lead them to behavior
that's going to be bad for them
in the long run.
And I couldn't agree more about this
burden of responsibility
that is seeming to just, you know,
being of an exponential rise,
this understanding, especially,
given what we've seen
in the past few years in all domains.
Noam, what do you enjoy most?
What do you love most about what you do?
Which part of it?
Well, first of all, to your point,
and I think an answer to your question,
I've had some kind of
strange experiences in my career.
When I started working
on the missile defense side,
I was a small part
of developing something
that I hoped no one would ever use.
Which is a very strange experience.
Building something
you hope no one use this.
Because if they're using it,
it means that there's war.
And it means that, you know,
your country and its people are in danger.
So, that was strange.
And fast forward to today,
I'm helping to develop a system where,
unlike so many other systems these days,
where it's all about engagement
and making sure that people's eyeballs
stay on a screen
and watch more ads, perhaps.
In our case, to your point,
you know, sometimes,
to do what's best for people,
it's actually about
not just delighting them,
keeping them engaged with software.
It's actually helping them avoid
making mistakes and taking actions
that could be detrimental to them.
And to that end,
I think what I love the most right now
is just the foundational impacts
that research can have
within an organization,
and the foundational impact that
a product like Wealthfront can have
on people's lives.
It's really, really meaningful.
And it's incredible to be part,
yeah, it's incredible to be part
of that ecosystem and have even a
small impact on the way things get built.
You know, I think that,
broadly speaking, in tech,
and certainly at Wealthfront,
we are trying to serve people.
Our mission at Wealthfront
is to put people above institutions,
to serve people.
And that's not something
that has traditionally existed
in the financial space or any space.
Really.
And as someone who is obviously curious
about people and understanding them,
why would not go through the path I did.
It's such a delight for me
that we are more focused on people
than ever before.
And we truly just want to serve.
And I know that, you know,
we have rightfully, in tech,
been criticized.
Certainly, in the past few years
for many things
that were absolutely wrong.
And there's still so much to work on.
But I'm a techno optimist.
I am optimistic about our impact.
I think that broadly speaking,
you know, and certainly,
when it comes to what's in our hearts
and what's in our minds
and our intentions,
we want to do great things,
we want to impact people's lives
in a positive way and give them access
to tools that haven't existed before.
And it's amazing when you think about it.
You know, when I think about education,
because I have young kids,
and watching them go through
the education system now,
there's still so much to do
and so much to improve.
And as I watch us going through
a global pandemic, a terrible pandemic,
which is cost way too
many people's lives,
I can envision
all of the incredible things
that are yet to come
that could improve our healthcare system.
And when I see companies
like Uber and Lyft and other companies
trying to revolutionize transportation,
and I think about the future of
kind of urban life
and how we won't be hopefully,
wasting so much space on parking lots
and parking structures and commuting
and drunk driving
and all of these things,
if they become something of the past,
that's an amazing, amazing thing.
So, I'm very excited.
And that's the best part, I think,
of being in my role
and just in tech in general.
And I have to say
that after this conversation,
I'm even more excited than I was before.
I consider myself a techno optimist
and I love that word.
I haven't heard it before
and I'm adopting it.
So, thank you for that.
And I'm energized by your vision
and the way that you perceive it,
and the shared responsibility
that you outlined here that I really hope
to take with me as well,
along with whatever ventures
I get to work on.
Noam, this has been such a pleasure.
Thank you very much for being
so generous with your time.
Before we leave,
I have to apologize
and put you on the spot one time
and ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
And I have to put techno optimist
as one of them.
That's for sure.
Yes, techno optimist for sure.
The second would certainly be extroverted.
I am an extremely extroverted individual.
I am struggling to exist in a time
when we are so disconnected
from our friends and family
and each other,
which is part of why
it's such a pleasure to talk to you.
There are many reasons
why it's a pleasure to talk to you,
that's one of them.
Just to connect with other people
is always fun.
And the last one I would choose
is curious.
I have always been
just a very, very curious individual.
I think, I credit that
to my mother in particular, I think,
of kind of gifting me with curiosity
and a love of reading
and a love of learning.
And it's the main reason
why I'm a researcher.
I'm just curious person.
Noam, this was such a pleasure.
Toda raba.
Thank you very much.
Continue doing good for people.
And I can't wait to see
what next things you do.
Because it's just remarkable.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Toda raba.